dude three and presents day you know
david letterman's back on Netflix I've
seen this he has his own show on Netflix
yeah actually dude he's got a beard now
babe look terrible yeah that's terrible
looks aged overnight I forget what it
was you never see him for lack I did
show in 1999 and he was so old looking I
really I was like damn he's really yeah
how did you do there it is so he's like
if my next guest me mall induction yeah
that's what your mall saying you'd see
that murders people mall Sam when you
did David Letterman did you they give me
three minutes four minutes six minutes
five minutes and he was um he didn't
want to meet you beforehand and then
while I was in the middle of my set he
was looking in his under his in his
drawer for what I'm so distracting I was
like oh she's looking at my sets wicked
you hear those thing I can figure out
those things yeah it was so [ __ ] and
then what and then did anything happen
after then it's a really helped you out
all back then 1999 now otherwise I don't
think you need Letterman for that
Natalie boy no it just didn't it just
was what it was different right but when
it was Tonight Show no back then it was
a big deal sort of I mean how did you
get on this all you wanted they were
doing new comedians and I was like a new
young comedian and they were like they
saw me at the comic strip they're like
he'd be great kicked off on the main
card with sage Northcutt and guty a man
you know a lot of people go man you're
so hard on sage Northcutt you know a lot
of people hate on sage Northcutt I think
there's a difference there I think a lot
of people hate on sage Northcutt because
he gets a lot of attention he's similar
to the the male version of Paige Vanzant
great looking people huge marketable
ceiling they're good-looking blonde not
a ton of experience but who knows where
they're gonna get to Paige is a little
different of an advantage because she is
a female fighter and she has room to
grow and the female fighters have not
been around as long sage is in a
completely different kind of
category he's at lightweight which is
one of the heaviest talented divisions
in the world if not the number one most
talented division in the world
lightweight welterweight there's an
argument there I'll probably go with
lightweight for now though you know so
when I look at Sage I think the number
one thing about sage Northcutt super
athletic great work ethic phenomenal
person finale human being I think the
biggest mistake his family and manager
ever made was getting him to the UFC so
early he doesn't have the experience
he's not really great at anything I
guess if you have to if this was a video
game he had to give a huge you know
what's his best attribute he's athletic
not that great jiu-jitsu not great
wrestling
all right striking there's not very
there's just not this huge kind of
upside I I don't see it and the bummer
is is he has the potential to be a world
champion but he will never be a world
champion because they've ruined his
youth and his time to grow and he has no
chance to gain experience and get better
now and then well in five years in five
years you can't keep giving sage
Northcutt guys like gu ta who he lost to
if this fight is not in texas safe North
Scott loses this fight and the only time
sage North got actually had a test
against a real up-and-comer a guy who
has actually a ton of potential a ton of
talent is Mickey gall mickey call you
know beat him so you know that he's just
not he's he's nowhere near the level of
the UFC fight and when you watch that
Northcote a fight you know you watch
that Brandon Davis Steven Peterson fight
you those first two fights is not at a
high level mixed martial arts that's not
a quality product that you put on Fox
it's just not and this is not a knock on
any of those four fighters it's not it's
if you watch them and then you watch you
know Don Cerrone for CNC or you watch
some of these other fighters it's just
it's just not to that level but we do
tune in they put a bunch of marketing
behind sage Northcutt if I had to bet
and I am a betting man you guys all know
this and I will
my money where my mouth is I think it
for years sage Northcutt has a different
job I think he focus on school maybe
he's some sort of fitness model I don't
know but I do not see the him in the USC
together and for you I was just a dick I
think I look Jack on the Franken three
because I was so much fun we're out
seven one of the best times ever ever
I'm even thought we should watch him
again man they're so good I hope things
are so funny so good can that stuff
laugh at all we have to do something
like that again yeah man we would sit
down and come up with ideas it was
amazing
but remember is really just you me and
Mitch yeah there's a three-man team
basically I'm Fox funded it but it was
all Brian it all fell on Brian and I had
to be honest right and the Mitch would
kind of help out do you and me would
come up with all these key ideas and I
think if we had more help if we actually
were the network who supported us and
you know in a production team I like a
legit but not Fox like there's Bracy the
Bad News Bears we're like Sandlot like
it was just can you hold the camera yeah
do a background no yep Kenny right no
I'll try it it was kind of that it would
always be that way we were like actors
producers directors and thank god brian
has experienced like nope we can't do
this and hope we can't do that it was
you know and Mitch Mitch is a veteran
you know but it was it was so much fun
we do it people ask all the time but
we've been offered and off the pier like
they should do it we should do it you
and I just need find the time to do it
that was it to be honest like I my
Showtime thing going on now if I stand
up gone now II you have all your stuff
the good news awfully about your show
getting green let your spin-off which is
[ __ ] huge that's all you've ever
wanted hopefully it happens you know
that all this happens it's positive but
it's and it's all good and dandy but
snot as fun is when we do find that's
what I was thinking about that I was
like if we if you and I got a team
together a real team together and
decided to do a real sketch show it
could be dude I think it'd be as good as
any but before I pitch the show to show
time I met with you name a production
company I met with them and pitched from
this show and every single one they'd
mentioned what's up what about finally
kid what about you and Brian doing thing
and all avoid magic I go we're ready I
mean
we have a million ideas I know that
would build do not eat a variety sketch
show let's just do it and pull all our
friends into it like Joe Rogan like
Chris D'Elia like will SAS have a board
like Rappaport like like [ __ ] silence
yeah yeah Schuyler we have a roster of
dudes to guest star on that [ __ ] but you
could do it like you know like like the
Larry David show it's a exaggerations of
your life in these situations with Bryan
and Brendan and you have your friends
and yeah and just make it a little bit
over the top direct you know
[ __ ] that's what I want to do it that's
what's fun I know doing around having
fun now what I'm doing it's just
different cuz is it's it's not as fun
when you're not with your friends you
know I'm saying don't Iran I love all
you guys I work with what's not the same
now I could do that just the best one we
do and I would get an address that yeah
especially it was like because the best
would you and I would come with idea and
then when you see it executed like oh
[ __ ] that was school no